This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. I was on Facebook the other day when a friend request came in. I don't have a great memory for faces and names, so I found myself trying to figure out if I had met this person somewhere. But then, at the back of my mind, I remembered a study. It set my friendship choices on Facebook might be shaped by biases outside of my conscious awareness in my hidden brain. Michelle Hebel is a psychologist at Rice University who ran the Facebook study. She designed fictitious profiles for two men and two women. Both men were named Michael Davis, both women were Jennifer Davis, all the characters were
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。前几天我在脸书上看到了一条好友请求。我的记性不太好，记不清脸和名字，所以我当时在想，我是不是在什么地方见过这个人。但随后，在我的脑海深处，我想起了一项研究。它表明我在脸书上选择朋友的行为，可能会受到我潜意识之外、隐藏在大脑中的偏见的塑造。米歇尔·赫贝尔是莱斯大学的一位心理学家，她主持了这项脸书研究。她为两名男性和两名女性设计了虚构的个人资料。两个男性的名字都叫迈克尔·戴维斯，两个女性的名字都叫詹妮弗·戴维斯，所有这些角色都是
African-American. The only real difference between the profiles were the photos. One Photoshop version of Michael Davis and Jennifer Davis had lighter skin. The other had darker skin. Mickey Hebel sent out friend requests on Facebook on behalf of these fictitious characters
非裔美国人。这些个人资料之间唯一真正的区别是照片。迈克尔·戴维斯和詹妮弗·戴维斯的一个Photoshop版本皮肤较浅。另一个皮肤较暗。米奇·赫贝尔代表这些虚构的人物在脸书上发送了好友请求
to more than 1,000 people in a big American city. Since these were invented characters, most of the requests were declined. But there was a big disparity in how often whites accepted friend requests from the darker skin, michaels, and genifers. People were less likely to friend them. They were less likely particularly to friend the dark black males. If you follow these kinds of experiments, this finding is disappointing but not surprising. Using similar experimental methods, researchers have found disparities in the way professors spend time with students, how companies select job applicants for interviews, even how legislators respond to constituents. But something new is happening today. The biased decisions we once made in interpersonal
发给美国某大城市的1,000多人。由于这些都是虚构的人物，大多数请求都被拒绝了。但在白人接受肤色较深的迈克尔和詹妮弗的好友请求的频率上，存在着巨大的差异。人们不太可能加他们为好友。特别是对于肤色较黑的男性，人们更不愿意加他们为好友。如果你关注过这类实验，这个发现令人失望但并不令人意外。利用类似的实验方法，研究人员发现，教授陪伴学生的时间、公司如何挑选求职者面试、甚至立法者如何回应选民，都存在差异。但今天有一些新的情况正在发生。我们曾经在人际
settings are now being made on giant online platforms, where our actions have the potential to affect many more people. Think about the way you might look for a roommate. Once upon a time, you may have put up a flyer on a bulletin board and talk to people who responded. Today you might turn to sites such as roommates.com or Craigslist. Raj Gosha, a sociologist at Gautier College in Baltimore, recently conducted a roommate study on Craigslist using a technique similar to the one Mickey Hebel used on Facebook. We definitely found a pattern of preference or bias in favor of white sounding names. So for every 100 replies that a white sounding name got a Latina name got about 75 and an African-American name got about 65 or something like that.
环境中做出的带偏见的决定，现在正被做出于巨大的在线平台上，我们的行动有可能影响到更多的人。想想你寻找室友的方式。曾几何时，你可能会在公告栏上贴一张传单，并与那些回应的人交谈。今天，你可能会转向诸如roommates.com或Craigslist之类的网站。巴尔的摩戈蒂埃学院的社会学家拉杰·戈沙最近在Craigslist上进行了一项室友研究，使用了类似于米奇·赫贝尔在脸书上使用的技术。我们确实发现了一种偏好或偏见的模式，即偏爱听起来像白人的名字。因此，一个听起来像白人的名字每收到100条回复，一个拉丁裔的名字大约收到75条，一个非裔美国人的名字大约收到65条，诸如此类。
That is a huge difference. It's a pretty big difference, right? So if you're African-American, you'd have to spend about one and a half times as much time applying for housing as would somebody with a white name. So if you're African American, you'd have to spend about one and a half times as much time Applying for housing as would somebody with a white name on today's podcast We're going to delve into what happens when age-old biases rear their heads in a new and growing part of our lives What sometimes called the sharing economy? It's one thing if I want to discriminate about who I'm gonna have over on Friday night
这是一个巨大的差异。这是一个相当大的差异，对吧？所以如果你是非裔美国人，你花在申请住房上的时间大约是拥有白人名字的人的一倍半。所以如果你是非裔美国人，你花在申请住房上的时间大约是拥有白人名字的人的一倍半。在今天的播客中，我们将深入探讨当陈旧的偏见在我们生活中的一个崭新且不断增长的部分中抬头时会发生什么，也就是有时被称为共享经济的东西。如果我想对周五晚上请谁来家里
To have for dinner or who I want to have sleep over. But it's another thing when my private house starts to become my business. The sharing economy, platforms that allow you to hail a taxi, call a babysitter, find a room on Airbnb, rely on making what used to be business exchanges into semi-personal transactions. Your Uber driver sees your name and photograph. You see your driver's name and photo. It's supposed to increase trust, and there's every reason to think it does. But it also does something else. When you give people names, then you give people information about your ethnicity. You
吃晚餐或者请谁来留宿进行歧视，这是一回事。但当我的私人住宅开始变成我的生意时，就是另一回事了。共享经济，即那些让你能叫出租车、请保姆、在Airbnb上找房间的平台，依赖于将过去商业交流转化为半个人际交易的做法。你的Uber司机能看到你的名字和照片。你能看到你司机的名字和照片。这本该增加信任，而且有充分的理由认为它确实起到了作用。但它也带来了其他影响。当你给人们名字时，你就给了人们关于你种族的信息。你
give people information that they can use to look you up and figure out more cute about you. And that becomes problematic. Mickey was on a ship when I interviewed her. She's teaching at Semester at C. During the long voyage, she says, her students tell her about the many online platforms that they are using. There's a website called care.com. And it's a babysitting website where people advertise themselves as babysitters. And they have to put a picture of themselves on. So you can think about how, again, maybe I don't want a babysitter that is of that race. Maybe I don't want a babysitter that is of that gender. And so you begin to see where this very subtle type of discrimination
给人们提供他们可以用来搜索你并了解你更多信息的信息。这就成了问题。我采访米奇时，她正在一艘船上。她在“海上学期”项目教书。她说，在漫长的航行中，她的学生向她讲述了他们正在使用的许多在线平台。有一个叫做care.com的网站。这是一个保姆网站，人们在上面把自己宣传为保姆。他们必须放上自己的照片。所以你可以想想，同样地，也许我不想找那个种族的保姆。也许我不想找那个性别的保姆。所以你开始看到这种非常微妙的歧视是如何
can be very systemic. The sharing economy is unleashing new possibilities in our lives. These platforms allow us to meet more people, visit more places, get more connected. I'm personally a fan of many apps. But it also seems clear to me that these platforms provide a mechanism to amplify our collective bias. What's especially insidious about the biases on these platforms is that their consequences are largely hidden. If your request to be a babysitter gets turned down, you have no way of knowing if this
变得非常系统化的。共享经济正在我们的生活中释放出新的可能性。这些平台让我们能够结识更多的人，去更多的地方，建立更多的联系。我个人是许多应用程序的粉丝。但我也觉得很清楚，这些平台提供了一种放大我们集体偏见的机制。这些平台上的偏见尤其阴险的地方在于，它们的后果在很大程度上是隐藏的。如果你当保姆的请求被拒绝了，你根本无法知道这
was driven by racial bias. So I asked hidden brain producers Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak to take a few weeks and try to find people who were personally affected by such biases. They decided to focus on an important new part of the sharing economy, Airbnb. Imagine you're going on vacation with some friends. You do a quick search online, find a few hotels in the city you'd like to stay in. You pick one, ideally with a hot tub, and enter your credit card information. Great, you think. I'll set.
是不是由种族偏见驱动的。所以我请《隐藏的大脑》制作人玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克花几周时间，试着寻找那些受到此类偏见个人影响的人。他们决定把重点放在共享经济的一个重要新部分——Airbnb上。想象一下，你正和几个朋友去度假。你在网上快速搜索了一下，在你想去的城市找到了几家酒店。你挑了一家，最好带按摩浴缸的，然后输入了你的信用卡信息。太棒了，你心想。我都搞定了。
But then you get an email. We're sorry, but the dates you just booked aren't available after all. They were listed by mistake. Now, if this happened to you once, you might chalk it up to a weird website glitch. But if it happened to you over and over, something would start to feel funny. You might start to feel like it's something about you that's making these hotels suddenly unavailable. This is exactly how Christina Crittenden felt when she would try to use Airbnb to book vacations with
但接着你收到了一封电子邮件。很抱歉，你刚预订的日期其实不可用。它们是被错误列出的。现在，如果这只发生在你身上一次，你可能会把它归咎于一个奇怪的网站故障。但如果它一次又一次地发生在你身上，就会开始觉得有点不对劲。你可能会开始觉得，是因为你身上有什么原因，才让这些酒店突然变得不可预订。这正是克里斯蒂娜·克里滕登在试图通过Airbnb预订假期时感受到的
her friends. She would find a house that was listed as available, send a booking request, and I would get declined all the time. Christina got a bunch of similar responses. The whole suit always come up with excuses like, oh, someone actually just booked it. Or oh, some of my regulars are coming in town and they're going to stay there. I just haven't updated my calendar. But I got suspicious when I would check back like days later and see that those dates are still available.
和她的朋友们。她会找到一个标为可用的房子，发送预订请求，然后我一直被拒绝。克里斯蒂娜收到了许多类似的回复。整套西装总是找出各种借口，比如，哦，其实刚好有人预订了。或者，哦，我的一些老主顾要来镇上，他们要住在那儿。我只是还没更新我的日历。但当我过几天再次查看，发现那些日期仍然可用时，我开始怀疑了。
Kertina is black. And this is relevant because on Airbnb, both hosts and guests have their names and photos prominently displayed on their profiles. And this is actually one of the platform's selling points. It's supposed to make these transactions between strangers feel less anonymous and less scary. But it also made Gratina start to wonder if these rejections had something to do with her race. My name is Gratina.
克蒂娜是个黑人。这之所以相关，是因为在Airbnb上，房东和客人的名字和照片都在个人资料中显眼地展示出来。这实际上也是该平台的卖点之一。它本应让陌生人之间的这些交易感觉不那么匿名，也不那么可怕。但这也让格蒂娜开始怀疑这些拒绝是否与她的种族有关。我叫格蒂娜。
I have a very black sounding name and I also had my photo so I'm very clearly a black woman. And when she looked at the reviews that previous guests had left for these hosts? I never saw anybody who looked like me. So Kertina did what any good millennial does when they're frustrated. She took to Twitter. And I was just venting my frustrations and I just included a lot of screenshots of the messages that I was getting from people and I put the hashtag Airbnb While Black.
我的名字听起来非常像黑人，而且我还有我的照片，所以我非常明显是一个黑人女性。当她查看以前的房客给这些房东留下的评价时？我从来没见过任何长得像我的人。所以克蒂娜做了任何一个感到沮丧的优秀千禧一代都会做的事。她上了推特。我只是在发泄我的沮丧，我附上了很多人给我发的信息的很多截图，我还加了标签“黑人时期的Airbnb”。
She started hearing from lots of friends who had similar experiences. The most common response that I got was, oh yeah, that's why I don't use my photo. Like duh. Like I was the late one. And one friend who hadn't. One of my friends who was actually black, he responded to me and said, well, I've never had an issue.
她开始听到许多有类似经历的朋友的声音。我收到的最常见的回复是，哦对，这就是为什么我不用我的照片。就像“废话”。就像我是最后一个知道的一样。还有一个没用过照片的朋友。我的一位实际上是黑人的朋友，他回复我说，嗯，我从来没遇到过问题。
And then he went back and checked his profile. And I guess he'd never want to use his photo. So he realized that the whole time he had been using a photo of some random white guy from our school. And so he's like, oh, maybe this is why I've never had an issue. So, Koutina decided to tweak her profile. I shortened my name to Justina, which is a name that I go by in work and in other settings. And I changed my photo to a landscape. Ever since I changed my name and my photo, I've never had any issues on Airbnb. Now, it's impossible to say exactly why
然后他回去检查了他的个人资料。我想他从来没想过用他的照片。所以他意识到，一直以来他用的都是我们学校某个随机白人男性的照片。所以他说，哦，也许这就是为什么我从来没有遇到过问题。所以，库蒂娜决定调整她的个人资料。我把名字缩短为Justina，这是我在工作和其他场合使用的名字。我把照片换成了风景照。自从我改了名字和照片后，我在Airbnb上就再也没有遇到过任何问题。现在，很难说为什么
Cartina was rejected by those specific hosts. But a recent study shows racial discrimination on Airbnb is widespread. I'm Michael Luka. I'm a faculty member at Harvard Business School. I'm an assistant professor of business administration. Michael Luka and his colleagues Benjamin Adelman and Dan Savirsky sent out fake Airbnb requests to real-life hosts So we sent out 6400 requests to stay with people and we kept every request the same the only thing that was different about the request The profiles attached them either had African American sounding names or white sounding names
卡蒂娜被特定的房东拒绝了。但最近的一项研究表明，Airbnb上的种族歧视非常普遍。我是迈克尔·卢卡。我是哈佛商学院的教员。我是工商管理的助理教授。迈克尔·卢卡和他的同事本杰明·阿德尔曼以及丹·萨维尔斯基向现实生活中的房东发送了假的Airbnb请求。所以我们向人们发送了6400个住宿请求，我们保持每个请求都一样，请求唯一不同的地方是附带的个人资料要么是非裔美国人听起来像的名字，要么是白人听起来像的名字
So like does Brad get the same number of responses on Airbnb as Jamal. And unfortunately, we could see that there was a very different response rate and acceptance rate for African-American guests relative to white guests. Having an African-American name leads to roughly a 15% lower chance of being accepted as a guest on Airbnb relative to having a distinctively white name, holding all else constant. To put this in perspective, Airbnb isn't some little start-up anymore. It's one of the largest players in the hotel industry worldwide. In 2015, more than two million listings were offered on the platform from hosts around the world.
所以，比如布拉德在Airbnb上获得的回复数量是否和贾马尔一样多。不幸的是，我们可以看到，非裔美国房客相对于白人房客，其回复率和接受率有着非常大的差异。在其他条件保持不变的情况下，拥有一个非裔美国人的名字，在Airbnb上被接受为房客几率大约会降低15%，而拥有一个鲜明的白人名字则不会。从这个角度来看，Airbnb不再是什么小初创公司了。它是全球酒店行业最大的参与者之一。2015年，全球各地的房东在该平台上提供了超过两百万个房源。
That's nearly four times as many rooms as the Marriott Hotel chain. You can even run to Castle. You can even run to Castle. And it's not just vacation rentals. People are finding housing on this platform for months at a time. So discrimination on Airbnb is discrimination in the housing market. Michael Luka and his colleagues think people could be discriminating without even knowing it. Buying a lot of people is something that is accidental.
这几乎是万豪酒店集团房间数量的四倍。你甚至可以租城堡。你甚至可以租城堡。而且不仅仅是度假租赁。人们在寻找这个平台上的住房一次长达几个月。所以在Airbnb上的歧视就是住房市场的歧视。迈克尔·卢卡和他的同事认为，人们可能在甚至不知道的情况下进行歧视。很多人买东西是偶然的。
What Michael Luka is talking about is unconscious bias. These hidden associations we have that affect our behavior without us realizing it. It's unlikely that most hosts are saying to themselves, I'm going to reject this person because I don't want to write to a black person. I mean, maybe some people are intentionally discriminating. There are probably some people like that,
迈克尔·卢卡所说的是无意识偏见。这些我们拥有的隐藏联想会影响我们的行为，而我们却没有意识到。大多数房东不太可能对自己说，我要拒绝这个人，因为我不想把房子写给一个黑人。我的意思是，也许有些人是有意歧视的。可能有一些这样的人，
but Michael Lucas suspects the way Airbnb's platform is designed is triggering the associations people have of some racial groups. So because names and photos are the first thing people see, it may also be one of the first things they consider consciously or unconsciously when choosing a place to stay. Hiennes-Kali's looked at five major cities in the US, and discrimination was happening across the board. We saw that there is discrimination among cheap listings, expensive listings, in diverse neighborhoods,
但迈克尔·卢卡怀疑Airbnb平台的的设计方式正在触发人们对某些种族群体的联想。因此，由于名字和照片是人们看到的第一样东西，这也可能是他们在选择住处时有意识或无意识考虑的第一批事情之一。Hiennes-Kali研究了美国五个主要城市，歧视普遍存在。我们看到，在廉价房源、昂贵房源、多元化社区中都存在歧视，
in homogenous neighborhoods, among White House, and among African American hosts. I actually spoke to Mike Luca last week. That's David King, the brand new director of diversity and belonging at Airbnb. He knows this is a problem, and he wants Airbnb to be a leader on fixing it. There is a racial bias in platforms platforms and we are working with Mike Luca and any other
在同质社区、白人房东以及非裔美国房东中也是如此。我上周实际上和迈克·卢卡交谈过。那是大卫·金，Airbnb刚刚上任的多元化与归属感总监。他知道这是一个问题，他希望Airbnb能成为解决问题的领导者。平台中存在种族偏见，我们正与迈克·卢卡以及任何其他
external interested parties and how do we address and fix this problem. One thing that could fix the problem is just getting rid of names and photos or making them last prominent. But Airbnb doesn't think that would improve their platform. The photos are on the platform for a reason. Number one, it really does help to aid in the trust between the guests and the host. And secondary to that is safety. You want to make sure that that guest that shows up your door is the person that you've been communicating with. But David King also pointed out
外部利益相关者合作，探讨如何解决和修复这个问题。解决这个问题的一个方法就是摆脱名字和照片，或者让它们不那么显眼。但Airbnb不认为这会改善他们的平台。平台上保留照片是有原因的。第一，它确实有助于促进房客和房东之间的信任。其次是安全。你想确保出现在你门前的房客就是你一直在交流的那个人。但大卫·金也指出
there's a lot of opportunity for Airbnb to do good. They're bringing together people from all different backgrounds who wouldn't normally meet. We've done some recent reports in Chicago and New York, pointing out that underserved communities, especially African-American communities, have benefited quite a bit from our platform, usually in neighborhoods where there are few hotels. One of those neighborhoods with few hotels
Airbnb有很多机会做好事。他们将来自不同背景、平时不会相遇的人聚集在一起。我们在芝加哥和纽约做了一些最近的报告，指出服务不足的社区，尤其是非裔美国人社区，从我们的平台中受益匪浅，通常是在几乎没有酒店的社区。那些几乎没有酒店的社区之一
is Washington DC's Anacostia. The neighborhood is on the edge of city limits, on the other side of the Anacostia River The neighborhood is on the edge of city limits on the other side of the Anacostia River from the capital on the Washington Monument. It's a neighborhood with a lot of big box doors and empty lots, but also row houses and families that go back generations. We went there to visit Airbnb host Sinta Keeling.
是华盛顿特区的阿纳科斯蒂亚。该社区位于城市边缘，在安那考斯蒂亚河的另一侧，与国会山和华盛顿纪念碑隔河相望。这是一个拥有许多大卖场和空地，但也拥有世世代代居住的联排别墅和家庭的社区。我们去那里拜访了Airbnb房东辛塔·基林。
Hi, how are you? Sinta owns a three-story townhouse in a new development. She rents out two rooms on Airbnb. There's a fitness room, cable and high-speed internet, solar panels, and slippers for all of her guests. I love the slippers, first of all. So, I do know. Sinta is a super host, and we're not just saying that because of the slippers.
嗨，你好吗？辛塔在一个新开发项目中拥有一栋三层的联排别墅。她在Airbnb上出租两个房间。这里有健身房、有线电视和高速网络、太阳能电池板，还有为所有房客准备的拖鞋。首先，我太喜欢这些拖鞋了。所以，我确实知道。辛塔是一名超级房东，我们这么说绝不仅仅是因为拖鞋。
It's an official designation she's earned from Airbnb. Based on positive reviews from her guests, her responsiveness to booking requests, and the fact that she's never canceled a booking. It shows Airbnb travelers she's been verified as a good person to stay with. Sintis says as a black host in a black neighborhood that's important. She feels like she gets held to a higher standard than other hosts. This neighborhood is called Capitol View and it's 98% African-American double digit unemployment. We asked him to weather her race and the racial composition of her neighborhood made it harder
这是她从Airbnb赢得的官方称号。基于房客的正面的评价、对预订请求的响应速度，以及她从未取消过预订的事实。这向Airbnb的旅行者表明，她已被验证是一个适合留宿的很好的人。辛塔说，作为一个黑人社区的黑人房东，这一点很重要。她觉得自己比其他房东承担更高的标准。这个社区叫国会山景观（Capitol View），98%是非裔美国人，失业率达到两位数。我们问辛塔，她的种族和社区的种族构成是否让她更难
to get gas and she said. Absolutely. Yeah, no, I had one. I've had some instances where people will ask me all these questions about unsafe and I'll say, you know, I'm a black Filipino woman. I take, we take great pride in our community. This is absolutely a good place for you to stay and I'll say those things and then they'll be crickets.
招揽到房客，她说。绝对是。是的，不，我经历过。我曾遇到过这样的情况：人们会问我关于不安全的所有这些问题，我会说，你知道，我是个黑人菲律宾混血女性。我们对我们的社区感到非常自豪。这里绝对是个适合你入住的好地方，我会说这些话，然后就会鸦雀无声。
They'll just not book. But Sinta also said there were great things about Airbnb. For one thing, it brings her a steady second income. Airbnb brings business to the stores and restaurants that don't typically benefit from the tourism industry. It might even help change people's perceptions of anacostia. Airbnb's slogan is, Belong Anywhere. And there's some truth to it.
他们就是不预订。但辛塔也说Airbnb有很好的地方。一方面，它为她带来了稳定的第二收入。Airbnb为那些通常无法从旅游业中受益的商店和餐厅带来了生意。它甚至可能有助于改变人们对阿纳科斯蒂亚的看法。Airbnb的标语是“四海为家”（Belong Anywhere）。这确实有几分道理。
Sinti Keeling told us a story about one of her guests that drove this message home. He came back from being out for the day and told her, I took the bus back and I was the only white person on the bus. And it was all these black people. I was the only white person on the bus. And it was all these black people. And I asked myself, were they going to hurt me? Am I unsafe? And then I realized they weren't hurting me. And nothing was going to happen to me.
辛塔·基林给我们讲了一个关于她的房客的故事，这个故事深刻地传达了这一信息。他外出一天回来后告诉她，我坐公交车回来，我是车上唯一的白人。车上全都是黑人。我是车上唯一的白人。车上全都是黑人。我问自己，他们会伤害我吗？我不安全吗？然后我意识到他们没有伤害我。什么都不会发生在我身上。
Like they were just sitting there normal. And he was saying this in a way that he was like he mentally realized the horiteness of that he was saying with the same time he was just being honest about what he was thinking and that he arrived to the stop and just said come off and like nothing had happened to him and it was just this shock. Sentence says she knows that some people won't run from her because she's a black host in a predominantly black neighborhood. But here's the thing she's glad those people don't run from her because she's a black host in a predominantly black neighborhood. But here's the thing, she's glad those people don't book with her.
就像他们只是正常地坐在那里。他说这话的时候，好像在精神上意识到了自己所说的话是多么可怕，与此同时，他又只是在诚实地表达自己的想法，当他到达车站下车时，什么事也没发生在他身上，这就是那种震惊。辛塔说她知道有些人不会向她租房，因为她是一个主要黑人社区里的黑人房东。但问题是，她很高兴那些人不会向她租房，因为她是一个主要黑人社区里的黑人房东。但问题是，她很高兴那些人不会向她预订。
The strange thing about Airbnb makes it tough is I really don't want a racist guest in my house because I live here in the space so I don't need to feel uncomfortable, you know, the other way. But if you just feel like, well, you know, maybe I'll give this a shot that I'm willing to be open-minded. The fact is Airbnb is not the same thing as a major hotel chain. Hosts have discretion on the platform, but guests don't have the same legal recourse as hotel customers if they feel they've been discriminated against.
Airbnb奇怪的地方在于它很艰难，我真的不希望一个种族主义的房客进我的房子，因为我就住在这个空间里，所以我不需要感到不舒服，你知道，反过来也一样。但如果你只是觉得，好吧，你知道，也许我会试一试，我愿意保持思想开放。事实是，Airbnb与大型连锁酒店不同。房东在平台上有自主权，但如果房客觉得受到歧视，他们不像酒店顾客那样拥有相同的法律追索权。
We spoke to a couple lawyers for this story, and the legal picture is a little murky here. It isn't clear who, if anyone, is liable for discrimination on a web-based platform. So Airbnb does offer this opportunity to experience different cultures, to meet people you wouldn't normally meet. But sometimes, hidden bias is getting in the way. And people like Kratina and Sinta are paying the price. That's Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak reporting on people who feel they have personally experienced bias in the sharing economy.
我们为这个故事采访了几位律师，这里的法律情况有点扑朔迷离。目前尚不清楚是谁，如果有的话，对网络平台上的歧视承担责任。所以Airbnb确实提供了体验不同文化、结识平时不会遇到的人的机会。但有时，隐藏的偏见正在阻碍这一切。像克蒂娜和辛塔这样的人正在为此付出代价。那是玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克关于那些觉得自己在共享经济中亲身经历过偏见的人的报道。
When we come back, Maggie Max and I will discuss potential solutions to the problem. Support for this podcast and the following message come from the all new 2016 Toyota Prius, making getaways more thrilling thanks to a double wishbone rear suspension and a lower center of gravity. With modern, striking lines, standard by LED headlights and an uncompromising sense of style, the 2016 Prius has an edge at every angle. The all new 2016 Toyota Prius is what's next. Support also comes from Atlassian. Today nearly anything is possible, and if we can dream it,
当我们回来时，玛吉、马克斯和我将讨论该问题的潜在解决方案。本播客及以下信息的支持来自全新2016款丰田普锐斯，凭借双叉臂后悬挂和更低的重心，让出行更加惊心动魄。2016款普锐斯具有现代、醒目的线条、标准双LED大灯和毫不妥协的时尚感，在各个角度都占据优势。全新2016款丰田普锐斯就是未来。支持还来自Atlassian。如今，几乎任何事情都是可能的，如果我们能梦想它，
teams can build it. So how do you bring everyone together to realize their shared vision? With Atlassian, makers of software for teams, Jira, Confluence, HipChat, and BitBucket, give your team everything you need to organize, discuss, and complete shared work. Atlassian works to help teams large and small ascend to new heights to create what's next. Visit Atlassian.com. Atlassian, team up. Thanks for listening, Dave, and Brain. If you haven't already, check out the MPR-1 app on whatever device you're using to listen to this podcast.
团队就能构建它。那么，如何将所有人聚集在一起实现他们的共同愿景呢？有了团队软件制造商Atlassian的Jira、Confluence、HipChat和BitBucket，为你的团队提供组织、讨论和完成共同工作所需的一切。Atlassian致力于帮助大小团队登上新高度，创造未来。访问Atlassian.com。Atlassian，携手共进。感谢收听《隐藏的大脑》。如果你还没有收听，请在你用来收听本播客的任何设备上查看MPR-1应用程序。
All month, you can hear the newest episode of Pop Culture Happy Hour a day early, exclusively on MPR1. Find Pop Culture Happy Hour, Hidden Brain, and stories from your local public radio station, all on MPR1. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We're exploring the many ways in which the sharing economy might allow hidden biases to flourish. As apps in the sharing economy become an increasingly large part of our lives,
整个月，你都可以在MPR1上独家提前一天收听《流行文化欢乐时光》的最新一集。在MPR1上寻找《流行文化欢乐时光》、《隐藏的大脑》以及来自当地公共广播电台的故事。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们正在探讨共享经济可能允许隐藏偏见滋生的多种方式。随着共享经济中的应用程序在我们生活中占据越来越大的比重，
they have the potential to create great disparities. Producers Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrac are in the studio with me now to talk about potential solutions. Hi Max. Hi Shankar. Hey Maggie. Hey Shankar. Maggie, if I understand correctly,
它们有潜力造成巨大的差异。制作人玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克现在和我一起在录音室里讨论潜在的解决方案。嗨，马克斯。嗨，香卡。嗨，玛吉。嗨，香卡。玛吉，如果我没理解错的话，
Airbnb actually gives hosts a mechanism to avoid this problem. It's true. There's this feature called Instant Book, and it's exactly what it sounds like. Basically, as a guest, you can book a room just like you would a hotel without waiting to be accepted by the host. Why would hosts want to offer this option? Well, it's much more convenient for guests, so I think you're more likely to get bookings if you offer instant book. And then it's also easy for hosts because if you're renting out your whole house and you don't really care who stays there, you can just offer this option and not deal with it. And is there any evidence that this feature is actually being used to avoid discrimination on Airbnb? Yeah, Max and I actually talked to the sky, Reed Kennedy, he's African-American,
Airbnb实际上为房东提供了一种避免这个问题的机制。确实如此。有一个名为“即时预订”（Instant Book）的功能，它听起来就是那个样子。基本上，作为一个房客，你可以像预订酒店一样预订房间，而无需等待房东接受。为什么房东会想要提供这个选项呢？嗯，这对房客来说方便得多，所以我认为如果你提供即时预订，你更有可能获得预订。而且对房东来说也很简单，如果你在出租整栋房子，而且你真的不在乎谁住在那里，你就可以提供这个选项而不用去处理它。那么，是否有任何证据表明这个功能实际上被用来避免Airbnb上的歧视呢？是的，马克斯和我实际上和这个人聊过，里德·肯尼迪，他是非裔美国人，
and his experience with Airbnb was very similar to Curtinas. And so after being rejected, I think in that case, four times within the same day, four reasons again that weren't specified, I started to see a pattern. So Reed complained to Airbnb, and Airbnb gave him a credit,
他在Airbnb上的经历与库蒂娜的非常相似。所以在被拒绝后，我想在那次情况下，在同一天内被拒绝了四次，原因同样没有具体说明，我开始发现一种模式。所以里德向Airbnb投诉了，Airbnb给了他信用额度，
but he was struggling to use this credit because he was still having trouble booking a place. So he used Insta book. And ironically, the host was a black man who may have been using the Insta book feature for the same reason I was. So Max, what I'm hearing Maggie say is that they might be a design solution for the psychological problem of bias. Yeah, and this is similar to a solution that Michael Luca came up with.
但他一直在努力使用这个信用额度，因为他在预订地方时仍然遇到麻烦。所以他使用了即时预订。具有讽刺意味的是，房东是一个黑人男子，他使用即时预订功能的原因可能和我一样。所以马克斯，我听到玛吉说的是，他们可能有一个针对偏见这一心理问题的设计解决方案。是的，这类似于迈克尔·卢卡想出的一个解决方案。
He worked with a computer scientist and they developed this Google Chrome app called Debiased Yourself. It removes photos and names from people's profiles, so you can't discriminate even by accident. And didn't Michael Luca say he actually got this idea from Orkestress? He did.
他与一位计算机科学家合作，开发了这个名为“消除你自身的偏见”（Debiased Yourself）的谷歌浏览器应用程序。它从人们的个人资料中删除了照片和名字，这样即使是无意中你也无法歧视。迈克尔·卢卡是不是说过他实际上是从交响乐团那里得到了这个灵感？是的。
So it used to be that back in the day, Orkestress were overwhelmingly male. And people may have thought, oh, there's just more male musicians, or maybe they're just better, but then there started to be a shift in orchestras, where there were more women, and researchers went back and looked at this, and they found that there had been a change to the audition process, where there was now a screen in between the judges and the person auditioning. And Mike Lucas says, this is something that Airbnb should be doing only on a larger scale.
所以过去在过去的日子里，交响乐团绝大多数是男性。人们可能认为，哦，只是有更多的男音乐家，或者也许他们只是更好，但后来交响乐团开始发生转变，有了更多的女性，研究人员回过头来研究了这个，他们发现试镜过程发生了变化，现在在评委和试镜的人之间有一个屏幕。迈克·卢卡说，这是Airbnb应该做的事情，只是规模更大。
One of the things that I love about the digital world is that it gives us the opportunity to choose exactly where to put screens and where not to put screens. So I think we have a host of new decisions that we can make as market designers that will decide how inclusive a society we have or how much discrimination we want to encourage or allow. I have to say it might not all be about the information that you're hiding. It could also be about the information that you're emphasizing.
我热爱数字世界的一点是，它给了我们机会来精确选择在哪里放置屏幕，在哪里不放置屏幕。因此，我认为作为市场设计者，我们可以做出大量新的决策，这些决策将决定我们拥有一个多么包容的社会，或者我们想要鼓励或允许多少歧视。我必须说，这可能并不完全取决于你隐藏的信息。这也可能关于你强调的信息。
Raj Gosal, this is a sociologist at Gauter College who did the study on Craigslist, suggested that we might want to be playing up certain kinds of information. Perhaps colleges and universities can play a role in this and perhaps websites like Craigslist or roommates.com could do more to actually like front load information about people's living habits or cultural identities. What time people get up and go to bed, what level of messy they are, that sort of thing. Rather than immediately hitting people over the head with somebody's name, just
拉杰·戈萨，也就是在Craigslist上做研究的戈蒂埃学院的社会学家，建议我们可能想要发挥某些类型的信息。也许学院和大学可以在这方面发挥作用，也许像Craigslist或roommates.com这样的网站可以做更多的事情来真正前端加载关于人们的生活习惯或文化身份的信息。人们几点起床睡觉，他们有多凌乱，诸如此类。而不是立刻用某人的名字给人们当头一棒，只是
because all the evidence we have, evidence from other studies just suggests that race in names is such a powerful signal to people that we probably don't actually want it to be the first thing or the immediate thing that people see in our deciding by. Yeah, that's a really interesting idea. Another option would be to offer trainings about unconscious bias to hosts. So Airbnb has actually already taken the step of training their employees and some hosts
因为我们拥有的所有证据，来自其他研究的证据只是表明名字中的种族对人们来说是一个如此强有力的信号，以至于我们可能实际上并不希望它成为人们决定时看到的第一件事或直接的事情。是的，这是一个非常有趣的想法。另一个选择是为房东提供关于无意识偏见的培训。所以Airbnb实际上已经采取了培训其员工和一些房东的步骤
in recognizing and combating unconscious bias. And maybe if they make that information available on a larger scale, hosts will start to check their own biases. Another idea that we've heard is to provide feedback to hosts. So Airbnb could send hosts and emails saying, here are the requests you received and here are the guests you accepted. Now, if someone doesn't want to host people from certain racial groups, this feedback wouldn't do much.
在识别和打击无意识偏见方面。也许如果他们大规模提供这些信息，房东就会开始检查他们自己的偏见。我们听到的另一个想法是向房东提供反馈。因此，Airbnb可以向房东发送电子邮件，上面写着：这是你收到的请求，这是你接受的房客。现在，如果有人不想接待来自某些种族群体的房客，这种反馈不会起太大作用。
But for those who might not mean to discriminate, it could be enough to nudge them in the right direction. Well, that's interesting stuff. Thanks so much, Max. Thank you. Thanks, Maggie. Thanks, much Max. Thank you. Thanks Maggie. Thanks Shunker. The Hidden Brain Podcast is produced by Karam Agar Kalasen, Maggie Pennman, and Max Nesterak. If you like this episode, consider giving us a review on iTunes. It will have other people find the podcast.
但对于那些可能并非有意歧视的人来说，这可能足以将他们朝着正确的方向推一把。嗯，这些都是有趣的东西。非常感谢，马克斯。谢谢你。谢谢，玛吉。非常感谢，马克斯。谢谢你。谢谢玛吉。谢谢香卡。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉姆·阿加·卡拉森、玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作。如果你喜欢这一集，请考虑在iTunes上给我们写个评价。这将帮助其他人找到这个播客。
We're going to be talking about this episode on social media, using the hashtag Airbnb Wild Black. Do join the conversation. I'm Shankar Vedantantham, and this is NPR. If you're looking for something else to listen to this week, check out the Ted Radio Hour. This week the show touches every third rail, race, abortion, even the Israel-Palestine conflict. On this episode, Ted speakers offer ideas on how we might do more than just tolerate the
我们将在社交媒体上讨论这一集，使用标签“黑人时期的Airbnb”。请加入对话。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。如果你这周想听点别的，请查看《TED广播节目》（Ted Radio Hour）。本周节目触及了每一个敏感话题，种族、堕胎，甚至是巴以冲突。在这一集中，TED演讲者提出了关于我们如何不仅能容忍
people we disagree with, but rather learn from them. but rather learn from them. Listen to the Ted Radio R podcast at npr.org slash podcast and on the NPR1 app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与我们意见不合的人，而且能向他们学习的想法。而是向他们学习。在npr.org slash podcast和NPR1应用程序上收听《TED广播节目》播客。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。